[Music]
what's the hardest thing you've ever
been doing six years ago my mother had
bone cancer and I nursed her through all
of that and I was with her when she died
so that was definitely the hardest thing
I've ever been through
takes a really long time and everyone
will tell you that it gets better but it
actually does get better it may take
years but it gets better when I was born
my parents were never together they it
was just kind of like a mistake thing
that happened like some party no one
wanted me as a kid so I just got passed
around from family to family just moving
schools never had the same friends never
stay in the same area it kind of [ __ ]
me up but like it made me who I am today
got me to where I am
I like built bridges baculum and
everything so my mom was a drug addict
went through a bunch of stuff my dad was
just busy doing his own thing
so I really didn't have a consistent
family or friends and then when turned
17 I just got I joined the military got
to Illinois and now it's all in the past
but
it was probably hardest thing I walked
into a long relationship dead in my
house
do you have any advice for other people
who might have gone through the same
thing
but you have to realize that it's not
your fault and it does get better in
time does your hardest thing ever mister
is a active addiction heroin addiction
how do you get through
asking for help you know about listening
to society and ask for help work through
it work through your problems in your
pain heal I would say probably growing
up without my dad that's not the
toughest thing I've ever had to do it I
guess find other people who were willing
to support me and care for me and I've
learned to kind of keep that message
going and pass on my goes so fine love
get well the loss of my cousin when I
was in sixth grade she was driving drunk
and drove off of a cliff so that was
very difficult for my entire family and
she was only 21 the death of my mother
and my aunt's in all four days apart
that was pretty bad I lost my mom to
drunk driving and four days later my
aunt had a heart attack so
it's happening so quickly
that was our than you get to understand
especially since neither one of them had
insurance so my sister and I had to pay
for everything not expecting it so that
was that was a rough few months have any
advice for other people who get health
insurance cherish your time with your
loved ones because it's it's repeated
and cliched but it really is true you
don't know when you're going to go and
you don't know how long we have with
somebody so any small grudges let him go
rescue I'm a lifeguard and I made a
rescue of two kids and that was really
hard so like you think both okay the
most the emotional part that was the
hardest because you're thinking that you
you you can make it but at the same time
it's it's waiting for you
you know the kid was waiting for me and
it was hard to think that you couldn't
make it that was the difficult part the
rip current starts to pulling them
inside the the ocean I saw them I so on
and my partner we we both run he go
first I was right behind him and then I
listened the boys screaming about help
ayuda in Spanish and oh my god
it feels like super super hard choking
you know because you don't know what
where it is the the waves didn't let me
see the next time remember because it
was too fast is that I was with a kid
and she was crying and asked asking me
for the for his little brother and
everything was was well I went through a
lot of abuse with my mom
ever since I was younger because she was
a single mom she don't know how to take
out her anger on anything so it ended up
being on me and for the longest time
because she taught me to be so
codependent on her I didn't know that
what she was doing was abuse and it was
really difficult for me to leave
and then when I finally did leave I felt
guilty about it about leaving her even
though she had hurt me so much and that
was really difficult to go through
because I I would I knew I was doing
what was best for myself but it still
felt selfish and being unsure of myself
was like awful I still always feel like
unsafe and unstable
I never feel grounded because she taught
me to be grounded and only her and only
her her dysfunctional behavior and so I
don't know how to find comfort in things
that are good for me
have any advice for someone
don't second-guess yourself too much
don't worry about what other people say
or what they think of you because you
know yourself more than anyone else and
no one can tell you how you've
experienced things and no one can
convince you that the things you've been
through are wrong
having someone addicted to drugs in your
family it's kind of torn my whole family
in two different directions and made it
so that we have to constantly watch this
person and spend money on it definitely
someone that has let drugs take over
their whole life and trying to watch
them hopefully not kill themselves I
would say that was that's probably the
hardest thing that I've ever had to go
through my piece of advice would be to
just trying to find a way through love
instead of hate
I said got the three triangle that I
went through in one month so the lost
money's a breakup of relationship and
getting thrown under the bus by eight
eight to eight of the girls I work with
you just have to move forward
you know this is life yeah
hardest thing I've ever been through is
sort of ongoing it's living with chronic
depression
I just get through it by
put one foot in front of the other every
day and just keep getting up in the
morning so
so I make it three years ago I was on a
hayride and it was right before
Christmas it was our carriage pulled by
horses and we stopped for a minute to
take pictures and I stood up and the
horses jerked really hard and I
literally catapulted off the hay wagon
onto the concrete and I shattered my leg
in many many pieces and I'm on a
three-year recovery now and it was
really hard because I'm some of it I
just love to walk and run and I love to
ski and ice skate and I'm just a really
active person and now I have to walk
with a brace and it's a huge adjustment
for me but I will say that through all
of that I felt God's presence
and I found his love that the worse had
hurt in the heart the weaker I got the
closer he got to me probably leaving my
home at a very early age home situations
are like never good and no one really
has a perfect relationship with their
parents but I thought I thought the
boundaries that they gave me weren't
enough for me to expand so I wanted to
go past the boundaries that my parents
had set for me and go into my version of
my own boundaries cuz it was very hard
and like change is hard for anybody and
especially when I was that young
the hardest thing I've ever been through
was watching my family react to the loss
of my grandfather after he lived with us
I think just in your moments that you're
still with those people who are alive
and healthy to always make sure that you
end every conversation on a good note
and always let that person who's sick
know how much we love them and care
about them it would probably be an
emotionally and verbally abusive
marriage and divorce probably just
having my family and close as close as
they are to me they helped me get me
through a really tough time and I
actually did counseling for a year which
I would definitely recommend counseling
never be afraid to get help
losing my nephew he was only 2 months
old but seeing my sister go through
something so devastating really
had a crazy impact on my life it really
about my family and to I wanna say one
of the biggest depressions that I've had
to go through so
my dad getting diagnosed with cancer the
retime
and yeah just the whole journey in the
process
the ups and downs you think you're gonna
like have a you know like these are get
better and then things get worse
yeah just the whole process it's hard to
describe unless you've really gone
through it I guess moving to Portland
Oregon from my home in Detroit
I left fine everything that I had ever
known for almost 30 years and had to
completely start from scratch and I
almost gave up a lot but it was also
definitely the best thing that I was
ever going through Winston Churchill
said if you're going through how keep
going and he was totally right when
you're faced with something that's
really difficult it's probably when
you're going to be faced with the most
joy in the end it's worth sticking with
it what's up guys my name is Mariah and
I'm the owner of this channel I'm also
the person behind the camera and I
thought I'd take a minute to thank all
the subscribers I gained so far and
maybe ask new years to hit the subscribe
button if you liked this episode or if
you're a fan of my channel in general
learning a lot thank you